I don't like cancel culture
but James Comey and Andrew McCabe and
Peter strzok and Lisa Page need to be
canceled
that I don't want to send them to jail
but I think they need to be canceled I
think they need to be kind of like you
know banished from polite Society let's
talk about the FBI and how we go about
that and then how we deal with this
larger question of things of like how do
we rebuild trust and confidence not just
in the FBI but in the political process
or in our culture and just as uh to tee
that off the uh uh The Listener or the
the viewer Colin uh for five dollars
which you can do at YouTube you can pay
money and we'll always read your
question but he writes we know the FBI
is corrupt and doj is controlled by
Biden why do we expect anything to
change Congress won't gut the entire
federal government uh Eli can you or is
uh can we look at what Durham you had
mentioned this before
Durham does not come up with
um a um a series of reforms uh Zach do
we have some language about what Durham
you know what he does kind of suggests
yes in terms of reform for the uh
he ultimately suggests uh appointing a
career position for a non-partisan FBI
agent or lawyer to challenge fisa
applications and every other stage of
any investigation where it's a
politically
sensitive investigation so that that's
the one recommendation that he makes we
also have uh you know an appetite among
Republicans this is uh representative
Andy Biggs of Arizona who's on the house
Judiciary Committee saying defund and
dismantle the FBI which honestly I'm
open-minded to just a wholesale like do
we need to is this agency even working
at all anymore but I'm curious what you
think of and we'll also point out that
Vivek ramaswamy who we interviewed a
couple weeks ago was saying that he said
that you know the FBI should just be
dismantled because it is too far gone
and rebuilt from the ground up what that
means but yeah Eli what what should
happen specifically to the FBI in order
to make it less prone to this kind of
behavior and other types of system or
recurring mistakes it seems well the
first thing is I think you separate the
domestic intelligence function from the
FBI from the law enforcement function so
I would take out all the intelligence
stuff
that what that's in the FBI it's a big
part of the FBI it's like Hoover build
all that stuff in the 20th century
against the Communist party and the
Soviets it should go to something else
um maybe a new agency
um but it should not be under the same
roof as the cops cops and spies should
not co-exist because spies break laws
and rules and cops enforce them so as a
very basic point we do not want the same
people who are responsible for sort of
uh countering intelligence threats or uh
spying on potential terrorist cells
in the same building as the people who
are just there to you know catch
fraudsters and stuff like that and how
did 9 11 how did the response to 911
including you know the Patriot Act but
not limited to that how did that
um you know did that uh steroid up uh
Jagger Hoover's initial
conception of the intelligence gathering
uh you know an infiltration aspects of
the FBI or you know
that's a great it's a great point
um so in in a piece I wrote a few months
back for commentary magazine
um you know can can the X there it is
can the FBI be saved from itself and can
we be saved from the FBI
um I get into the fact that I think it's
been missing is that right before 9 11
the FBI uh came very close to kind of
having the sorts of
huge reforms that it so desperately
needs but it got out of that because
um Louis free who was the director
um resigned in shame after uh Robert
Hansen was caught who went undetected
for 20 years as a originally a Soviet
agent and then a Russian agent
um and they sort of went after the wrong
nice to see somebody who made a smooth
transition from the Soviet to the
Russian side of things it's only right
it's only sad that he was an American
FBI agent but right
um so that was a huge blow but there
were several other things the Wen Ho Lee
case was completely botched they ended
up could you briefly describe what the
Wen Ho Lee case because that was
something that was everywhere for a
while and then it disappeared and it is
a disturbing you know ins of you know
personification of when the FBI gets
something really wrong yeah sure I mean
this is a guy who worked for one of the
top secret doe nuclear labs and he was
accused of being a spy for the Chinese
and the FBI was absolutely convinced of
that there were a number of you know
there were a number of cases you know
stories that were written I think in in
major elite Publications like New York
Times accusing him of such and then it
ended up that they were totally wrong
and he sued the FBI and won because uh
they defamed him and even though I think
they eventually charged him with
something far less than I was like
taking a uh yeah a classifier a secured
computer home or something like that
yeah but it was like it was far less
than whatever yeah right but then that's
then there's like you know the screw up
uh at Waco I mean there's all kinds of
things that happened in the 1990s that
really were very bad for the FBI and
it's traditional friends on the Capitol
Hill
um usually Republicans like the FBI sir
Chuck rashley at the time you know kind
of gives a speech but it was only in his
80s so he was you know oddly a young
spry you know spring chicken
um was uh you know I mean like saying
hey my daddy loved the FBI but I at this
point don't think I can trust them and
that was in 19 that was in 20 that was
in like 2000 you know or 2001 when he
said that and it's only kind of gotten
worse so what happened is so Free's gone
and then Bob Mueller comes in to be the
FBI director so once you have a new guy
you're not going to blame him for
everything else and then
the FBI is kind of blamed for not
putting connecting the dots on 911 again
though that's that's Louis Free's fault
it's not Bob Mueller's fault he he was
only there like a week or two before 9
11 is his first day
um
and so the problem what they said was
that there were too many restrictions
and this is very important that FB to to
the to the fisa the the foreign
intelligence surveillance Act
um and that's the system that the FBI
uses to try to get the court to issue a
warrant to spy on American citizens and
so they needed to remove those
restrictions and knock down this wall
between collecting intelligence and
doing the law enforcement work and which
is what they they thought that was the
problem
um what's rarely mentioned is that
before 9 11 there were these fisa
scandals which
you know produced all this outrage the
fisa Court rebuked members of the F you
know for basically the same kind of
thing that we saw with Carter page his
FBI agents just totally making false BS
statements to the court they were
ignoring this time limits on various
surveillance warrants so they're
continuing to listen to lines when they
shouldn't have or even in some cases
they would continue to collect
information on phones after the number
had gone to somebody else I mean all
kinds of things like this that were
violations of like what they were
supposed to do and violations of the of
of the Court oversight
it looked really bad for a while it was
the reason why we have something that's
called the woods procedure which is that
now allegedly for every fisa warrant
that you submit to the court you have to
have a separate file at FBI that shows
why every fact in that application
documented is accurate so you have to
have it's a sort of a another one of
these safeguards another one of these
reforms but what did we learn from
Horowitz what we learned from Horowitz
is that the FBI ignores the woods
procedures all the time and that gets
back to the main point of Dorian which
is that if you have an institution
that's filled with people
who who weren't who don't have integrity
then you can have all the reforms you
want it's not going to make a difference
so there has to be something that is
also in addition to I think removing the
intelligence collection from the bureau
which is a no-brainer
I mean this is going to sound strange
because normally I don't like the idea
I'm I'm like you reason magazine and
many others and I'm very aware I don't
like cancel culture
but James Comey and Andrew McCabe and
Peter strzok and Lisa Page need to be
canceled
that I don't want to send them to jail
but I think they need to be canceled I
think they need to be kind of like you
know banished from polite Society they
should not be asked to you know appear
on prestigious Think Tank panels or to
teach at universities or to appear as
law enforcement analysts on CNN and
something like that would show that
there are at least some sort of social
consequences
for FBI leaders who have fallen so far
of the mark and have been have been so
have lacked so much integrity and then
maybe we have a chance at sort of trying
to change what appears to be a really
I'm worried about the culture of the FBI
at this point because it's not limited
to just I mean listen this is an
egregious case but we see it time and
again
um that oftentimes these G-Men kind of
think there's a law unto themselves and
we can't have that so I I'd like to see
some some social consequences for some
of these folks that was an excerpt from
reasons live stream with Eli Lake
dissecting the Durham report if you want
to watch the whole conversation go here
if you want to watch another excerpt go
here and tune in next Thursday at 1pm
Eastern time because Zach Weissmuller
and I here will be back here with a
great guess thanks for watching